von delmenhorst bis münchen vom
erzgebirgskreis bis mainz in immer mehr
städten und landkreisen stehen die
warnzeichen auf rot die solcher hat jede
lücke genutzt die wir gelassen haben
der anstieg ist alarmierend dabei müssen
wir uns immer klar machen die zahlen von
heute zeigen nur die ansteckungen vor
etwa zehn tagen wie viele menschen dann
in zwei wochen tatsächlich erkrankt sein
werden auf die intensivstation müssen
oder gar sterben kann keiner exakt
vorhersehen
der blick auf unsere nachbarländer zeigt
höchste vorsicht ist geboten
die politik hat gestern einiges
geschafft maßnahmen wie die sperrstunde
um 23 uhr wurde die frage wie viele
menschen sich privat oder öffentlich
treffen dürfen wurden bundesweit
einheitliche grenzwerte geknüpft die
teils großen regionalen unterschiede
beim infektionsgeschehen hat die politik
so ausdrücklich anerkannt
trotzdem herrscht weiter zu viel streit
zu viel profil sucht zu viel unklarheit
zum beispiel beim bußgeld für masken
verweigerer oder einer strengeren
flächendeckenden masken pflicht oder
beim beherbergungs verbot de facto sorgt
es dafür dass knappe test kapazitäten
für tourismus genutzt werden
das schafft ungerechtigkeiten und
unübersichtlichkeit das schadet im kampf
gegen korona die politik sollte deshalb
die kraft zu mehr einheitlichkeit finden
und das beherbergungs verbot doch noch
schnell kippen
bevor die gerichte das überall anordnen
denn es ist doch klar je
unterschiedlicher die regeln desto mehr
schwindet das verständnis und damit die
kraft das virus zu besiegen
föderalismus ist eine stärke
deutschlands aber föderalismus gebietet
nicht nur vielfalt föderalismus verlangt
auch solidarität das heißt in diesem
fall die akzeptanz bundeseinheitliche
vorschriften
denn es geht doch um viel die gesundheit
jedes einzelnen
die leistungskraft und stabilität
unserer gesellschaft